begrüße sie herzlich zu der heutigen
sitzung die teilnehmer hier im raum und
natürlich auch die zuschauer zu hause
die sich das ganze live jetzt anschauen
können
und zwar wie gesagt das gesetz geht
jetzt auch für sie die sie hier im
seminar sitzen sie können gerne den
livestream mitverfolgen
lukas diesen youtube kanal und ich sehe
schon das ist gerade schon online und
sie können auch sicher
die folien der heutigen sitzung
unterlagen also auf diesem auf diese
adresse direkt unter dem youtube-video
passiert zwar half auch sie heute geht
es um gomez nicht erlaubt es der 20
heute geht es um thomas von der kieler
die subtypen und es geht um immanuel
kants theorie der lüge und um eine
theorie die das anfang einer versuchen
entwickelt wurde und die sich mit dem
thema durchschnitt also bockmist
beschäftigt als boxer wurde schild mit
lügen zu tun hat wollen wir heute
braucht uns gemeinsam erarbeiten
so jetzt aber nochmal zu beginn eine
kleine brücke beim rückblick wissen sie
noch was für sieben todsünden war wie
sie lauteten am besten auch noch in der
traditionellen reinfeldt als wenn das
wenn sie das aus dem seminar mit neben
die anzahl um genaue benennung der sind
tot sind die usa noch gibt
die richtige reihenfolge haben sie schon
sehr viel gelernt was ist ganz oben
immer lateinisch ist es super
und dann wissen sie was dann kam
dann kam das was wir selbst der letzten
sitzung sehr negativ bewertet haben
habt ihr genommen habt ihr und dann
gleich
ihre zahl kann jetzt ein bisschen
schwierig wir hatten gesehen dass der
neid so ein bisschen der mitte steht
zorn
also andersrum erst die brust dann fülle
rückhand und dann ganz am ende die tk es
gibt natürlich ganz viele verschiedene
anordnung dieser hauptsünder todsünden
und ein kommilitone hat eine sehr gute
idee dass man das ganze ist so begründen
kann
das ist in die abnehmens von der
geistlichkeit das also hochmut ist alles
sehr innerlich angelegenheit
das ist eine einstellung da hat man so
was wie dunkel oder eitelkeit und
habgier ist auch eine geistige haltung
aber es wird doch immer auch zum leiten
und zugezogenen emotionaler und am ende
für dabei holen und zu bringen
trägheit hingegen da nicht mehr so sehr
emotional angelegt aber ihre passivität
eines sich gehen lassen wo halb gar
nichts geistiges mehr stattfindet also
man könnte sagen es abnahme von
1 ticket warum sollte der abnahme von
geistigkeit oder ein nationalität haben
sollte die bitteschön den besonders gut
seien dabei das wird der beste aber wenn
das ist ein schlechter sei als erwartet
als die zu reagieren oder die
geistlichkeit drin ist ist nicht
geistigkeit als solcher internet
qualitäten gut zu nehmen kann man sie
und was wäre jetzt die am montag
dass man nun könnte man das jetzt
verteidigen
diese ansicht das ist tatsächlich abgabe
intellektualität oder geistigkeit aber
dass die zur abnahme nicht bedeutet also
schlecht wird dass es besser betragen
also dass trägheit besser ist als hoch
und wird dafür dass nach dieser
rangfolge an putin
das wäre jetzt das argument ganz nette
übrigens mal
da stets auf das problem ich kann selber
formulieren also wir könnten sagen da
ist dass man gemeinsam diskutierten
sitzung war dass hochmut und habe geht
es damit intellektualität enthalten ist
er wird mir gedacht dann trägt man
könnte doch jetzt denkt da wo mehr
gedacht wird da ist es dann amerikanisch
besser da wo weniger dachte da ist es
schlecht bekommen
warum ist die nicht so warum muss
demnächst die frage richtig auch gerne
an die zuschauer im internet
sie dürfen gerne das ganze rein posten
wir haben schon vier zuschauer zu früher
morgen laufen
warum ist geist nicht gleich gut oder
intellektualität vielleicht nicht gleich
mit dem guten zu sitzen
es so eigentlich die kernfrage aber
unseres ganzen jahres bedeutet die
tatsache dass irgendwo intellektualität
von und geist was auch immer
mentale phänomenen beteiligten warum
bedeutet das nicht an sich schon das ist
dann besser gut ist ja
ja genau also da ist mehr bewusstsein
spiel könnte dazu haben oder man könnte
auch sagen er macht der mensch mehr
gebraucht und seine freiheit erleben auf
einer schlecht ist oder in seinem
verstanden aber eben auch schlechte
weise er missbrauche das was eigentlich
zum guten angelehnt ist und deswegen ist
besonders schlimm weil er es eigentlich
eine zum guten einsetzen also diese
frage ist hier sind dass man sich immer
bewusst wird das kann man mit diesem
konzert sehen erst mal um was handelt es
sich überhaupt für ein phänomen ist es
eine emotion ist etwas emotionales ist
es eine handlung oder ist es eine
einstellung momentaner mentale
einstellung und wir haben natürlich
gesagt zorn
gefühl des neues sinne gibt es eine
gefühls komponente
aber es ist nicht nur gefühlen wie zb in
führung
im hungergefühl ist sehr wenig
rationalität unterhalten im mai hingegen
mit immer verglichen bleiben das jetzt
immer auf einem vergleich
die hat doch mehr als ich und dann wird
begründet da gibt es in der begründung
und der förderverein das ist vielleicht
auch eine einstellung da ist aber sehr
wenig ratsam alle total da wird einfach
nur genuss diverser der bonus und andere
objekte also man kann immer
unterschreiben ist es eine form von
handlung ist er gefallen haben die
mortalität diese zwei alternativen hat
ja aristoteles vorgebracht den wir ja in
der letzten sitzung ausführlich
besprochen hat und wie er sei es gibt
zwei arten von lastern anzeigenbereich
lastet die den bereich der handlung
entspringen uns den bereich der effekt
jetzt muss man sich natürlich fragen
konnte aber das tut was diese sieben
todsünden vollständig durch handlungen
vettel beschreiben oder glauben sie
nicht dass kam jetzt kürzlich dass er
einen bereich vielleicht übersehen hat
oder gar nicht behandelt hat kann man
die sorgen produzenten hinreichend
klassifizieren
durch die einteilung in handlungen oder
effekt du wirst du nicht nur was drittes
viertes
glauben sie dass das vollständig ist
aristoteles sagt ja nicht dass es
vollständig ist auch alles nicht so ein
bisschen nachlassen
auch youtube zuschauer einfach einen
posten ist es vollständig über die
fehler als ich glaube da fehlt noch was
nämlich so was die innere einstellung
überhaupt einstellen effekt bisher nicht
unbedingt einstellungen und handlungen
sind bestimmte einstellungen behandlung
noch viel mehr
also eigentlich schade hat aristoteles
mit den effekten und mit den handlungen
nur zwei kategorien von vielen anderen
jetzt hier behandelt die das die form
der das moralischen erfassen kann
da fehlten das würde ich so was wie
innere handlungen zum beispiel wird auch
wie haltern einstellung und jetzt gehen
wir mal zurück hier auch seine theorie
der mesut ist und das ist
wie gesagt es gibt hier so extrem wie
immer wir können den wiederholungen
einsetzen oder so und jetzt sagte auch
es tut lässt
wir können ja nicht beliebigen effekte
oder emotionen einsetzen und dann daraus
die mitte nehmen und dann kommt das gute
raus des serviceteams hotel ist also wir
finden einen weg zwischen extremen haben
sie noch ein beispiel wo das gelingt wo
man sagen kann wir setzen da extreme
einem lebensmittel und dann folgt tugend
daraus das war das beispiel
[Musik]
und ja gesagt demut wäre nur extrem
erfasst wird ist die frage ist mut der
effekt er würde wahrscheinlich sagen
perfekt als geheimfavorit ist auf jeden
fall affekten wenn wir den mond jetzt
steigern eine extremform was kommt dabei
raus
solitary namen gemacht die furcht in die
extreme formen bringt dann folgt daraus
feinheiten zu ihr sagte die medien
zwischen ist die tapferkeit ist sie so
für die mitte als sie am teile des mutes
hat also man mit getraut sich etwas
man rennt nicht gleich weg aber man ist
vorsichtig haben ist nicht blind sein
herz macht blind und ohne bedacht als
man könnte sagen hier
tapferkeit bekommt ihre reflexivität so
ein bisschen durch die furcht für das
moment der furcht immer so ein bisschen
ist alles okay sondern dem orientieren
konnte die entschiedenheit
durchsetzung zu den entscheidenden
moment und das funktioniert es aber
nicht bei allen effekten oder handlungen
und geben sie mir mal ein beispiel wo
das nicht funktionieren wo ich etwas
einschließen kann
fahrer b und dann sagen kann ich bin
jetzt da sind mit und dann bekommen wir
die toten draußen
[Musik]
mir gar nicht sicher ob das zu wollen er
hat glaube ich ganz hatte er gar nicht
so sehr als etwas schlechtes angesehen
also ganz verschwendungssucht war auch
für den in rom an die die mitte nehmen
konnte das war so was wie genau und noch
schadenfreude positionen phänomen
da geht es nicht und beim night hatten
wir gesehen ok haben wir ja als dritte
hauptzone also offensichtlich hat alles
fokussieren gewissen nähe
das sei bei manchen dingen immer sind
nicht mehr aus wenn die pflanze die sind
drin so schlecht jetzt könnte man sich
fragen und sich dann alle sieben
todsünden intrinsische schlecht wir
haben jetzt hier habt ihr es ja was auch
mal damit gesetzt wird und wir haben
gesehen dass aristoteles
interessanterweise geils nicht als etwas
anzieht was im trend so schlecht ist und
was eben durch dieses verfahren der
mesut ist er in eine richtige mitte
gebracht werden kann dann ist natürlich
die frage ob er dann andere begriffe
wahrscheinlich sowieso zu verstehen die
sparsamkeit angesagt und nicht so sehr
wie gehabt gibt es also muss dann immer
ganz genau hinschauen was ist von
begriff ist ja mit sechs zuschauer und
drei bis nach steigen
alles gut das war also mit sehr kurzer
rückblick auch was tut was das rätsel
merken können ist also wie mir scheint
wir müssen das tun was ein bisschen
probieren anfangen ich sage jetzt noch
das teurere halben laster wissen oder
fall kalt es ist zumindest moralisch
problematisch ein richtiges laster
intrinsisch wäre so etwas wie
schadenfreude oder white oder als hand
gegeben aber diese extreme form ihr
jedenfalls dramatisch und erscheint
dabei anzusetzen und er ist damit der
mitte zu finden in cattolica also die
tore stehen mich am anfang
es müsse herausgefunden werden und zwar
durch wissen sie noch durch was was
alles total es hier angeführt hatte mit
welchen hilfsmitteln wird die tugend
herausbekommen
das war die klugheit front assist und
die reflexionen
wir müssen hier unsere intelligenz
einsetzen
das hat er dann bei der puffer wir
können uns fragen wie wir gut und ruhig
alles moment aufgehoben
die krankheit ist habe ich das ja auch
in der zusammenfassung geschrieben hatte
das irgendwie noch bebaut sind in diesem
epischen zinnen das können uns fragen
und zum schluss können wir uns fragen
inwiefern ist aristoteles anteilen
effekte oder handlung vollständig um
alle formen des unmoralischen erfassen
zu können ich glaube nicht dass es passt
oder alle zuallerletzt haben noch was
gemacht wir haben wir uns überlegt was
der unterschied zwischen dem mäßigen und
dem unbeherrschten es werden sich noch
der akku lasters und ehrat krater des
rates also
katrin heise neben herrschen und es ist
der unbeherrschte und wir haben dann
dann herausgefunden dass der
unbeherrschte nicht ganz so schnell ist
ps warum unmäßig als ubs wäre etwas von
dem aristoteles sagt das ist so was wie
so eine krankheit die ganze zeit
begleitet laut gelbsucht oder wasser
sucht das so was wie gesagt und die
unbeherrschtheit wäre elektrisch
anfahren der also instanz ankommt wo wir
aus dem rot gefahren aber damit einen
zustand des richtigen maße zurück und
die unmäßigkeit wäre dispositionen eine
charaktereigenschaft die nicht mehr uns
in die lage versetzt solchen mittel wege
zu finden das rechte maß der messe und
essen einfach verloren
so könnte man sich das vielleicht
vorstellen die um mäßigkeit deswegen ist
sie auch schlimmer als mutig und gehirn
statt die eigentlichen des mars hat anna
und zu geben aus dem willensschwäche in
einem antreten zu können
[Musik]
oder aber sie antreffen und ansichten
und dieser hier ist meine interpretation
wenn sie das anders sehen können sie das
gerne auch noch vor bringen ist
sicherlich auch interessantes thema ich
war kurz das publikum auf youtube ob der
ton okay ist bitter eine ganz kurze
rückmeldung dann dann weiß ich dass ich
so weitermachen kann
ok und nachdem wir uns jetzt aristoteles
zu gering
gehen wir weiter und kommen jetzt
endlich auf diesem weg mehr wir auf ihn
zu sprechen
der so genannte quellen er ist die
sportart geschrieben hat und wissen es
einfach den fragen die zu dieser tiere
sind zu klären die politik und da hat er
eine geschrieben eine quest uhr ist die
quests die frage die halo über das
schlechte und die ruhen uns jetzt erst
noch mal kurz ein bisschen anschauen
zwar haben
nach welchen kriterien die sich der
haupt laster haupt 10
und wie verhalten sich diese zudem laste
also thomas mann der queen wäre die
nächste station wir wollen ja nicht so
sehr nur historisch sein wir wollen
immanuel kant beginnen aber den zeugen
der schon noch mal mit behandeln sagte
vollmer die erste frage ist und auf eben
diese kreationen ab es geht immer um
fragen die gestellt werden
jetzt sagt er folgendes erste frage
lautet welche innerhalb laster gibt es
und welche ihr scheitern
bis 7 dämmen und jetzt kommt die ganze
rente verweis auf die ganze tradition
kriege oder große das ist ein wichtiger
zeuge dass die alters der auch wichtige
beiträge gemacht hat zur tradition der
sieben todsünden der sagt im 31
sandoval stück schritten es gibt sieben
hauptsächlich lastern nämlich einigkeit
im zorn trägheit habgier
das sind eigentlich die sieben todsünden
berlin statt
hochmut und in der ordnung wenn es auch
ein bisschen anders weil habt ihr kommt
als drittletzte und wo los kommt als
letzter und ist eigentlich nicht letzte
bei dieser haltung die wir jetzt uns
angeschaut haben
dagegen spricht dass die haupt offenbar
so genannt werden weil an einem während
andere sünden ihren anfang nehmen
umstand aber alle laster aus einem
einzigen lastern oder bloss zwei
timotheus 614 heißt es denn alle denn
die wurzel allen übels die begierde und
in zehn fünfzehn hochmut ist der anfang
einer sünde anzug gibt es nicht erziehen
so zu sehen so ist es immer bei dieser
plastik dass man immer verschiedene
meinungen aufführt und dann dass er im
krone contrat dann zu etwas an ergebnis
kommt also versucht die ganze tradition
zu führen
ja wir sehen sie es ist dass die wurzel
allen übels begierde nicht erhoben
das ist die ganze verweis auf die
tradition
[Musik]
hier sehen sie die anderen
offensichtlich erstmalig das revidierte
ist ja ja vielleicht etwas grundlegendes
nochmals habt ihr also noch etwas
besonders und illustrieren nach jemanden
vielleicht auch ein zu haben steckt
aber wie ist es mit der trägheit
völlerei würde noch gelingen aber trägt
doch das waren überhaupt nichts tun zu
wollen oder zu müssen das heißt ja nicht
umsonst auch das ist schlimm
die preise werden aber ist die trägheit
nicht noch viel weniger
und könnte man nicht seinen gästen die
trägheit nicht mal mehr das aufwändige
von energie enthalten ist träge sein zu
können
also man kann das natürlich sagen die
frauen wenn man jetzt träger mit
faulheit gleichsetzt dass die frauen
dazu mich wie betreiben um in den
zustand kommen zu können
und wenn sie den zustand sind dann
würden sie ihm vielleicht unbedingt
beibehalten wollen glaubt aber wenn sie
in dem zustand sind sie selbst nichts
mehr tun
oder sie hätten vielleicht ein auge
drauf dass der zustand nicht verhindert
wird das wäre dann die begehrte
vielleicht genau nach dem 1 1 zu sehen
ja genau da vorne einmal daran denken
haben aber man kann ihn
[Musik]
das ist wirklich fast schon scheint dann
wäre aber nicht mehr begehrt in amerika
die träger nicht mehr in der lage
begierde aufzubringen also wir sehen
hier gibt es probleme ebenfalls thomas
von aquin wir das jetzt auch noch mal so
da stehen lassen er will jetzt immer so
die tradition dafür also der bibel
finden wir eben einmal so eine aussage
dass es eine sünde ist als mitglieder
der und ein zünder
dagegen wurde eingewandt dass der
apostel oder gibt es eine meldung wenn
wir so gesehen war das der kosten an der
zitierten stelle von der regiert und
nicht wie von einer besonderen sünde
spricht sondern in sofern sie eine
allgemeine verwirrung des begehrens
haftung
dagegen spricht sofern die meedia.de ich
dir eine einzelstunde ist handelt es
sich um ein maßloses gier nach reichtum
das habsucht genannt wird und von dieser
begehrlichkeit spricht der posten an
dieser stelle
da sich die nervösen erster teammanager
614 euro steht der bereich werden wir
geräten versuchen und in die schlinge
des teufels teils
didier de welche die wurzel aller
gruppen ist eine eigene einzelnen sind
einmal weiter die laster sind trugen
entgegengesetzt nun gibt es aber nur
vier kardinaltugenden die ambrosius in
seiner kommentieren von lukas 6 4 stand
es 22
selig sind die geistig armen sagt es
gibt also nur vier hauptlasten wissen
sie noch was diese christlichen
kardinaltugenden waren ja
[Musik]
genau
und dann gibt es noch diese christlichen
tugenden kennen sie doch haben sie den
kopf die habe ich mir eine
zusammenfassung geschrieben
typisch christlichen
hoffnung war dabei liebe glauben diese
sachen erzählen aber nicht als die
werden auch ergänzend mit hinzugenommen
glaube liebe hoffnung zu diesen vieren
und gerade gegangen kardinal ohne die
aus der antike verwendet ein bisschen
auf 7 und lernen darin zudem ging es ist
okay jetzt könnte man sein muss machen
und glaube liebe hoffnung mit dem
zunehmend zu den vier kardinaltugenden
aber auch sieben dann können die den
sieben todsünden entgegensetzt während
die möglichkeit sah das auch die
tradition gemacht
es scheint doch folgendermaßen das seien
eine sind entsteht aus einer anderen auf
welche die erst abziehen so zum beispiel
wenn jemand nur das geld gewinnen will
übt die lüge als aufgrund der habgier
entsteht doch kann jedes beliebige
laster auf jedes andere begnügten ast
abziehen
daher ist kein laster hauptsächlicher
als ein anders das haben auch gesehen
dass es hier so eine verbindung zwischen
den einzelnen gibt also wie niemand das
geld wird so ist die logische folge aus
der abgeben
also man kann das
jene dinge die natürlicherweise auf
auseinander hervorheben kann man nicht
als gleichermaßen hauptsächlich
bezeichnen aber der neid und später auch
natürlicherweise aus dem hochmut
deshalb darf man den neid nicht als eine
hauptkunden jeden gut annehmen
h also hier wird jetzt gesagt dass die
folgerung beziehung zwischen diesen
verschiedenen auto zünden und der neid
ist eine bloße folge könnte man
vielleicht sagen
die frage ist nur dann die wie von
gestern die trägheit eine folge des
wohnung ist ja auch nicht
jedenfalls ist sie jetzt in diesem zitat
so ein bisschen klar geworden dass der
hochmut zu als die schlimmste todsünde
schildert die situation weiter lesen ein
bisschen weiter es scheinen jene laster
die bedeutendsten oder hauptsächlichen
zu sein die auch bedeutende zwecke
verfolgen wenn man sich jetzt auch der
unmittelbaren ziele der last der
fertigen biotech sind es sehr viel mehr
als 7
bezüglich der fernziele gibt es keinen
unterschied zwischen fischerei und
verlassen dass wir beide in der
fleischeslust ihren entferntesten
ausrichtungsort haben wird
auch daher ist es nicht sachgemäß 7
dazu kommen das hat man gesehen für das
sind neben einstellungen die eben auch
sinnlichen genuss razzien geben
verschiedene inseln aber es ist jetzt
endlich derselbe grund begierde
was ich besonders interessant finde ist
dieser hier ist der satz sagt jene lasst
es in die bedeutendsten die auch
gedeutete zwecke davon was wir verstehen
sie das
die fans sind die zwecke zum beispiel
der habgier oder sucht muss
die fans sind die verfolgen diese lastet
die bedeutendsten zwecke dem sie meinen
hoch warum verfolgt er bedeutendes leck
also wir können immer uns überlegen ja
[Musik]
oder wir einige touren und wir können
belegen aufpasst ist sie gerichtet
mit
außerdem kommen kollegen
damit könnten kritisiert
die gerichte teil für das fernsehen wird
das ist ein geistiges phänomen ist
ja
das
nein
[Musik]
hier
ja
hmm
okay sie würden also sagen der das
objekt des reports während man selbst
gibt es also nur dir selbst bezogen
[Musik]
ja ich denke es geht in die richtige
richtung
[Musik]
neben menschen in leipheim sind dass sie
auf ihre christlichen service
es ist es so dass der held nötige
entgeht sie den schaden in allem also
nicht aber dadurch dass er sich selbst
[Musik]
genau das ist geht auch in diese
richtung ging es ja auch noch ein
bisschen theologischen in der karibik
zum gewichtigsten den mitmenschen geht
man dann nicht mehr berücksichtigt
[Musik]
genau deswegen müsste man sagen als
objekt das ich aber immer dass mit der
trennung von gott untersten als
allmächtige sich so wird ist
interpretieren dass ich in so fern ins
leben und beschränkt ist vielleicht auch
ein mächtiger als etwas besonders als
etwas was sich bestimmten regeln geboten
ziehen darf jetzt endlich ein angemaßt
das anmaßen dessen immanuel kant hat es
dem eigenen dunkel genannt ganz
interessante eigenen denke ist verkannt
auch noch schlimmer als sowas wie selbst
lieben oder alten liebe hat der
eigentümer des kontinents grad ist
eigentlich ganz zentraler begriff
bekannte der in der zitrone mangel kann
der eigene dunkel ist einiges andere
nickt des hochrheins also hier nicht
gekannt spiel schweigend
aktion der sieben todsünden an und das
wäre jetzt der spannende frage können
wir den nächsten sitzungen fortsetzen
inwiefern finden sich bei kant diese
relikte der todsünden todsünden der
eigenen glückes ist das schlimmste war
kein gibt und zwar deswegen sind sie ist
was da mal haben sich schon mit dem
eigentümer bei kant befasst haben dass
im nächsten sitzung noch ein bisschen
der eigenen dunkel der bedeutet auch
nicht dass man sich selbst irgendwie vor
allem irgendwie arrogant sein das ist
zwar mit dimensionen kann sagt auch
eigentlich ja keinen spaß ganz hier das
ist der begriff der betreiber ist so
dass hier das subjekt sich vom city
gesetz also dem gebot des kategorischen
imperativs freispricht und das kann man
wiederum als eine säkulare form der
karnischen gottesbeziehung
interpretieren was bei in der tradition
bei thomas und gott ist ist bekanntlich
das sittengesetz dieser kategorie
diese absolute das absolute gebot der
noa und im reigen dunkelmann investieren
wir ein falsches korrigiertes verhältnis
nicht zu gott sondern es im gesetz wir
glauben dass das sittengesetz für uns
nicht gilt
das ist so die der grundsatz dass
eigentum künstlern wir verwenden darauf
auch für veranstaltungen für begründung
das nennt man kann wieder vernünftig
das ist dann seine theorie der
rechtfertigung machen wir jetzt das
nicht dem gebot nicht folge leisten
müssen warum mit einer ausnahme versehen
da gibt es immer noch spuren in der
neuesten tradition und hochmut scheint
für viele das entscheidende sei und die
bedeutenden zwecken könnten etwas
hier
hier eben jemand etwas verhandeln im gut
was besonders gravierend es hier wird
ein gottes verhältnis verhandelt oder in
form in form des eigentümers ihrem
verhältnis zur absoluten moral
verhandelt sie ist eigentlich das objekt
das absolute dass ich so viel man sich
absolut setzt in die ziel unbekannt für
sieben gesetzt
während dem sezieren
es trägt jetzt mal lust ist einfach ich
würde mal sagen was wirklich einstellen
als aufdecker produkt menschlicher leib
oder
nur das war ganz reduzieren ist die
reduktion eines anderen melden es seien
vielleicht nicht mal menschlicher konnte
auch menschlich bleibt erst einmal
zurück an
sodom und gomorrha deswegen komme ich
drauf haben sie die geschichte parat
zudem und gomorra da geht es wenn ich
mich nicht wenn ich mich nicht irre
darum dass die einwohner von ist
unglaublich dass die engel des wahren
glaubens kreiert die dort dann warum das
ganze
die kundschaft unterhalten dass die
sogar den mängeln an die wäscherin also
damit ist gesagt das muss nicht nur
menschlich
es geht jedenfalls dass sexualität
ebenso reduzierte nach dem genuss von
körperlichkeit sexualität im ganzen
situation und das vielleicht in einer
form die eben keine regelung
also die geschichte von sodom und
gomorrha ist ein gutes beispiel wo die
wollen die belege haben könnte für den
bonus dass die ein problem sein könnte
jetzt habe ich hier wo ich die wollust
bekanntlich gleich drei zuschauer
verloren aus kamenz schließen möchte
soweit es kommt auch vor dass man's will
aus guter absicht entsteht etwa wenn
jemand spielt mein eindruck almosen
geben zu können so eine sünde ist dann
aber von keinem der oben genannten
laster bedingt als entstehen nicht alles
suchen aufgrund des lieben angegeben
laster und das ist die frage
kann es sein dass jemand eine sünde aus
guter absicht geben
das ist eine ganz schwierige frage die
auch mit der frage der heutige sitzung
im zusammenhängt wer nämlich darf man
lügen in bestimmten größen
das geht
welche richtung wird jedenfalls dieses
problem scheint sich am geschmack hin
auszurichten
die wurst hingegen am tastsinn plan kann
von seiner wohnung muss nicht unbedingt
sein also dort bereiten auch andere
sinne einen gewissen genuss als es
sollten die hauptsächlichen laster
genauso an den anderen
festgemacht ich glaube thomas immer mehr
verschiedene fälle wie es heute morgen
gut an welches in der vest gehabt oder
die einen kaufen
die leiblichkeit vielleicht angesichts
10 aber wenn ich eben damit kurze
gewissen erfolg zu haben die nicht
sinnlicher natur sind geld oder sonstige
wieder folge ist es ja nicht mit einem
dritten sind verknüpft und sie merken
thomas gewinne erhöht jetzt verschiedene
optionen diese sieben haupt sünden zu
systematisieren zuordnen also bestimmte
objekte zu setzen
auf diesem zuge sind unterlag reich
bestimmung der systemische oder leben
kognitive und emotionale vermögen
genau das soll es nur von thomas märklin
gewesen sein also wir haben vertrauen
christian ist die staaten die eine
riesige umfang haben und es gibt es in
jeder der sieben todsünden ein ganz
großes kapitel
ich habe jetzt ihnen heute nur ein paar
zitat aus der einleitung gedacht es gibt
ja noch ganz liebe kapitel und zwar wie
gesagt gewinnt mit jeder todsünde und
wir werden dann auch immer wieder wenn
wir die gelegenheit haben zurückgreifen
auf thomas müller geht gewissermaßen
begleitend zum beispiel werden wir auch
nicht gekommen weil ich für sehr
interessantes phänomen und dann werden
mit auch ein bisschen thomas antrieben
zu nehmen
haben sie noch fragen zu tun ist da
jetzt hier niemand auf meine frage im
internet geantwortet hat ob der ton okay
ist gehe ich davon aus dass er okay ist
und dass ich so weitermachen kann
wenn sie keine fragen mehr zu haben
gehen wir weiter und zwar um diesen
linke
und ich habe ihn heute schon kurz
erwähnt er ist sicherlich der
wichtigsten philosophen der neuzeit und
sie wissen alle dass der ein neues
paradigma die moralphilosophie mal
gegründet hat dass man die demo
theologie nennen könnte weiß man sagt
dass die ontologie bedeutet
und ohne die
die
[Musik]
wäre
der pflicht und auch noch konkrete
szenarien kann um das sollen das sonnen
oder ein gebot und zwar nicht gott ist
nicht die zehn gebote gutes sondern um
das gebot der vernunft oder gesten
gesetzt
wenn sie sagen kann hat einfach den
begriff dodgers re formuliert im sinne
der aufklärung durch reine praktische
vernunft es gibt interpreten die lesen
kannst es kann hier eine moralische
rückgebaut
das können des drittels in der ein
vernünftig denn tisch oder zumindest
verwandt sein kann zeigt dass selbst
nicht aber man kann uns so dekretieren
dass diese das gedanke sich hier eine
moralische weise ausdruck dass zuletzt
aber und das darf man jetzt eben nicht
falsch verstehen wenn man sagt die
pflicht eine pflichten lehre kant hat
nicht so eine ethik entwickelt dass er
uns sagt besonders das tun dass jetzt
das tun dass uns das zu entlastungen als
die zehn gebote mäßig unsere pflichten
leere da erlebt es nach dem nicht denn
er sagt du sollst etwas tun oder was du
tun sollst das musst du selbst
herausfinden was da nicht tun sollst und
zwar mittels eines kriteriums könnte man
wiederum sagen da gibt es neben zu
aristoteles die nächste motors verfahren
wie wir aus bestimmten extremen täter
aus finden dass etwas formales diese
mission teils lehre sagt einfach nur wir
sollen extreme vermeiden und
einige subtilität wählen und ganz
ähnlich ist es bei kant auch der sagt
wir sollen so handeln dass die maxime
als unsere willens grundsatz sich
widerspruchsfrei gemeinde und damit ist
noch kein bestimmtes geburt gesagt
deswegen des pflichten wäre sicherlich
richtig
die lehre und dem pflicht aber die
pflicht ist etwas formal handels unter
der maxime des wissens hat das
subjektive handlungs grundsatz ein
allgemeines gesetz für alle gemeinden
ist es
[Musik]
und jetzt ist die große freiheit die
große debatte über die sich die leute
die köpfe zerbrochen haben kann man
wirklich aus zu anderen leerformel dem
kategorischen imperativ kann man daraus
wirklich gehaltvolle pflichten gehalt
für eine handlungsanweisung und auch
verboten ableiten
geht das überhaupt kann wird es sagen ja
aber wenn ich da irgendwas einsätze zum
beispiel dass ich mir etwas von jemandem
laie kann denn dass das depositum das
ist während ich es mir ausleih und im
anderen das versprechen gebe es immer
wieder zurückzugeben das ist ja mit dem
begriff ist geliehenen bestandes guten
position müssen also noch ein bisschen
vermeidung juristischer gefasst und dann
aber zugleich indem ich ihnen das
versprechen gebe für mich denke dass es
im video nicht mehr zurückgeben wenn er
merkt also winter jetzt verstärkung
sollte oder eben vergesslich werden
sollte dann in diesem fall gewissen
nicht mehr zurück wenn es nicht mehr
werden
und dann sagt dann würde sich das
depositum selbst aufheben
also damit meint er natürlich nicht
gewinne gegenstand danken plötzlich
zerstören würde
sind das neben dem begriff des deposit
uns als institution des depot
und dass es die möglichkeit gibt sich
etwas diese möglichkeit würde in letzter
konsequenz zunächst gemacht weil es
nicht mehr
die unterscheidung zwischen besitz und
eigentum anerkennen wird aus den kämpfen
hätte unterschieden
also jemand der etwas besitzt ist
nämlich gleich eigentümer dieser sache
eine mietwohnung das sind sie besitzen
aber nicht eine vertraglich können sie
bis jetzt dass sein aber es gehört eben
nicht immer zeigen und diese differenz
würde eben dadurch verloren gehen und
dadurch würde das ganze
die ganze institution dass der position
auch vor und gehen jetzt kann man sich
natürlich fragen ja wer sagt dass das
depositum als institution überhaupt
geben muss das waren zum einwand von
hegels spiel aber ich glaube durchaus
dass man kann damit viel zeigen kann
ok und von diesem hintergrund seiner
theologischen und pflichten leere räume
uns jetzt ein paar fragen stellen
nämlich warum bremkamp kategorisch ab
das ist eine frage eine andere frage
inwiefern ist ganz generell ist
verbote problematisch diese zwei fragen
stellen und gewesen jetzt einen
textlichen herumgeschickt hat hat jeder
von ihm den text bekommen wenn nicht
bekommen haben sollte oder auch in der
letzten mail sind nichts als nichts
bekommen
die entscheidung kann es sein dass der e
mail adresse unleserlich für mich war
und ist insofern sind die verteilerliste
richtig aufgenommen haben
sie finden aber alle von ihm wie gesagt
immer unter diesem video also praktisch
für die zuschauer hier unten direkt in
der beschreibung trend zu unterlagen
oder auch auf lukas oder in der app und
auch diesen text finden sie jetzt in der
füllung cast chancen die renten zu
mitlesen immer ein eigentliches beim
vermeidend es recht aus menschenliebe
hinzufügen von 1797 bekannt ist wie sie
wissen gestorben bis 1900 und an sehr
alt geworden und das war also ungefähr
sieben jahre vor seinem tod waren schon
recht betagt für die damals
in der schrift frankreich im jahr 1797
sechster stück nummer 1 von den
politischen gegen wirkungen von bernie
ecclestone ist folgendes seite unter 23
zitat der sittliche grundsatz ist eine
pflicht die wahrheit zu sagen würde wenn
man in unbedingt um vereinzelt nehmen
jede gesellschaft zur möglichkeit machen
den beweis davon haben wir in der serie
mit bach förderung der deutsche
philosoph aus diesem konzerns gezogen
hat des arbeitgebers zu behaupten dass
die bürger gegen einen mörder der
infarkte unser von ihrem verfolgte
freund sich nicht in unser haus
geflüchtet ein verbrechen zahlen würden
das ist dieses beispiel
er verfolgte den wunderstoff geben und
nachdem er die verfolgung seien gefragt
werden und dann würden sicherlich die
meisten stimmen doch einfach mal ab sie
zieht ja hier niemand wird sagen dass
man in einem solchen fall sollte oder
dürfte also wenn jetzt jemand ihr freund
freundin verfolgte von anderen wärtern
wird oder wer würde sagen dass man nicht
leben durfte er sagte dann sollte dürfen
wir sagt man sollte nicht würde niemand
ich dachte jetzt kommt mit ihren über
großes problem er kann heute sagen
dürfen auf gar nicht ok jetzt geht es
weiter
der französische philosoph der weg auf
zeitung mit 24 diesen grundsatz
erfolgreich ist eine pflicht die
wahrheit sagen der mit kämpfern pflicht
ist unzertrennbar von dem begriff des
rechts eine pflicht ist was bei einem
wesen den rechten eines an
widerspricht da wo es keine rechte gibt
gibt es keine pflicht die wahrheit sage
ist also eine pflicht aber nur gegen
denjenigen will ich ein recht auf die
wahrheit hat kein mensch aber hat recht
auf eine wahrheit die anderen schadet
und das ist jetzt das zentrale argument
das ist jetzt die zentrale punkte in
dienst gehen
das proton besonders also die dass die
grund der grundfehler den grund lüge ein
grund warum dieser these die er jetzt
hier genannt hat liegt in dem satz die
wahrheit das zeigt jetzt eine pflicht
aber nur gegen den jedem welch ein recht
auf die wahrheit hat zuerst anzumerken
dass ein ausdruck ein recht auf die
wahrheit haben ein wort um den sinn muss
wie man es sagen der mensch haben
entgegen
auf seine eigene wahrhaftigkeit das
heißt auf die subjektive wahrheit in
seiner person objektiv auf eine wahrheit
ein recht haben würde soviel sagen als
es komme wie überhaupt bei mein und dein
auf sein
ob eingegebener satzbau oder falsch sein
sollen
gestern eine schätzung abgeben würde
ok also macht jetzt hier erstmal so bis
zu einem begriffsklärung die zweite nun
ist die erste frage ob der mensch in
fällen wo er eine beantwortung mit
jahren ein nicht ausweichen kann die
befugnis das recht habe wohl wahr zu
sein
die zweite frage ist wenn nicht gar
verbunden sei mit einer gewissen aussage
wo sie in ein ungerechter zwingend nötig
ein wahrhaft es sein um eine
lebensbedrohende missetat an sich oder
einem dritten zu verhüten
sind all diese fragen
dürfen wir ja in solchen fällen nötigung
jemand verfolgt wird und mit dem zentrum
für wahrhaftigkeit im aussage die man
nicht umgehen kann ist formal pflicht
des menschen gegen jeden sie mag ihn
oder einen anderen daraus auch noch so
großer nachteil erwachsen und ob ich
zwar dem welche mich ungerechterweise
zusagen nötig nicht unrecht tue wenn ich
sie verfälschen so tue ich doch durch
eine solche befehl schon die darum auch
zwar nicht im sinne des juristen und
jetzt kommt der begriff lüge genannt
werden kann
im wesentliches teilstück der pflicht
behaupte unrecht
das heißt ich mache so viel an mir ist
dass aussagen überhaupt keinen glauben
finden mithin auch alle rechte die auf
verträgen begrüßt werden wegfallen und
ihre kraft einbüßen
welches unrecht ist das dem entscheiden
das ist jetzt das argument heimes und
man erkannte und youtube zuschauer
dürfen gerne auch mitmachen dürfen gerne
in den kommentaren schreiben ob dieses
argument ihnen eingeleitet oder nicht
müssen uns erst überlegen was ist dieses
argument zu machen kann
es geht also um aussagen die man nicht
umgehen kann weil man ja gezwungen wird
davon wird ja jetzt von diesem verfolgt
er zwingt mich deshalb ist der jetztzeit
hier hast du denn jetzt da versteckt
oder man kann jetzt da nicht schweigen
das ist jetzt auch zum thema was uns so
lange überlegen müssen könnt ihr nicht
einfach nicht was eigentlich sagen
nichts weshalb wir können jetzt nicht
und darum herumkommen nicht tun da eine
aussage die zeit fehlt ist als eine
proposition das sagen
ich sage nichts wäre ein ausstieg aus
diesem geben und nehmen von gründen das
wäre keine promotion nichts machen
werden müssen als obersten tätigen die
wahrheit mit fähig sind wohl daneben
sofern sie jemals wird fix sind überaus
als sagt eine pflicht des menschen gegen
denis marques team oder andern daraus
auch noch zusammenwachsen also der
mörder
ich sag die wahrheit und da kann noch so
große nachteil folgen der mörder geht
dann eben ins haus und findet sein
und ob ich zwar dem welche mich
ungerechtfertigterweise haben soll
benötigt nicht unrecht tue wenn ich sie
verfälschen
nun wird der mörder um recht wenn wir
ihn an blüten in einem solchen fall das
würde sagen
[Musik]
außerdem wird er möchte jetzt jemanden
und wir ja
[Musik]
diese gesellschaft ja davon dass sich
daraus ergibt
ist das eigentlich
ja es geht in die richtige richtung aber
achten sie noch mal drauf wenn es auf
die frage ob nicht dem mörder schaden
wird also nur der mörder jetzt sie haben
jetzt praktisch die ganze menschheit
schon in erwägung gezogen
das machen wir nicht
genau das meint sie auch aber die frage
darf wonach ist
[Musik]
als erstes jetzt erst mal dass ich dem
mörder diesem der mich zur aussage
zwingt nicht umwelt nicht sagen
der personell die wie duellen personen
diesem projekt nicht wem ich im glück
interessant
durch die nicht um rein oder auch wenn
er mich ungerechtfertigter weise außer
gehörte tue ihm nicht unrecht zu bringen
also wir dürfen das ganze nicht nur auf
diesen angehöriger beziehen und sagen
wie sie beide richtig gesagt haben wir
müssen es beziehen die auf etwas anderes
denn jetzt kommt so tue ich doch durch
eine solche fälschungen die darum auch
youtube werden kann im wm sind nichts
gehört jetzt kommt der pflicht überhaupt
nicht und was ist denn die pflicht
überhaupt der in richtung
hier haben
[Musik]
seit jahren so haben so gesehen
also war also der dieb lied zur wahrheit
wäre vielleicht so zu verstehen dass sie
einzelne fälle betrifft wo ich eben
immer die wahrheit sein muss und ihr
verhaftet werden so eine grundhaltung
die note ganzes leben betrifft aber
jetzt überlegen sie mal was das argument
weil man kann jetzt so argumentieren
dass er sagt ich würde aber die pflicht
verletzten deswegen ist es falsch
dann kann man ja fragen ja warum soll
ich es überhaupt tun das wäre ja so ein
bisschen tautologie das wirken
ich soll nicht lügen warum er werde
seine pflicht ist nicht zu hören
aber das wollte gerade bist
wahrhaftig
[Musik]
ich hoffe wir haben beschlossen werden
ja das geht auf jeden fall ich die
richtung wenn sie jetzt auch noch mal
beim zitat bleiben dass wir gerade dabei
sich das zu sagen
wie wir alle
sie sagt
wahrheit nicht durchgesetzt dass ich das
noch nicht ganz glücklich werden
ja sachen wir
die wahrheit dem aussetzen wäre jetzt
genau das hat keinen glauben finden sie
kennen das wer einmal lügt dem glaubt
man nicht zu kennen ich brauche also da
wird etwas grundsätzliches zerrüttet und
zwar eine institution wird zerrüttet
nämlich vertragsbindung oder die
institution des vertrages was wir doch
über diese richtung das depositum
beispiel präsentiert es geht meine
verdauung das ein grund strukturen die
wir eigentlich voraussetzen müssen
überhaupt vernünftig existieren zu
können dass die jeden tag durch
unmöglich gemacht
und wir brauchen aber diese kunst und
das ist eben jetzt keine tautologie
regel würde sagen es ist trotzdem
ethnologie erscheint aber es ist keine
objektive technologie jetzt immer und
sind sagen würde warum sondern sie nicht
anlügen
die pflicht ist und kann sich vor allem
warum das ist das eine pflicht
er bringt ihr weiteres argument ja weil
es geben unser grundsätzliches
vertraglich rechtlich krieg das
zusammenleben unmöglich machen würde
wir brauchen aber eines menschen eine
solche form ist es amtlich das wäre ein
boot auch das sagt der menschen hautnah
das andere nicht als die menschheit ist
wieder diese form des kategorischen atx
an das so dass sie nur eine maxime
jederzeit platziert einer allgemeinen
gesetzgebung müsse noch eine andere
formen des kategorischen imperativ das
mit der menschheit überhaupt und so
weiter sofort schaden soll
[Musik]
das verblüffende zusammenleben mit einer
kraft mit einem norbert finden in kraft
die sich zu neuer spielerinnen vertreten
fest
das ist die menschen und das subjektive
vernünftig geordnet regelte normativen
begründete koexistenz die würde dadurch
ihren unglücklichen als eine institution
die lüge also bloß als vorsätzlich waren
wohl vorsätzlich uhr mit deklaration
gegen einen anderen menschen definiert
bedarf nicht des zusatzes dass sie einem
anderen schaden müssen wie die juris als
einen anderen konkret ist tadellos dem
mörder schade ich dadurch nicht
man könnte sagen doch weil er mit mörder
will darüber jemanden geworden
und wenn ich mich dann wirklich jemand
sagen wir morgen ein schaden könnte man
sagen kann es ist die pflicht und in
individuellen mörder dem ich schaden
könnte wenn ich müde ich würde ihm gar
nichts erkannt wie juristen ist zu ihrer
definition verlangen
denn sie schade jederzeit an
den wind gleich nicht einen anderen
menschen doch der menschheit überhaupt
und dem city rechtsgültigen warm gemacht
als plötzlich unterscheidet den
konkreten menschen und der menschheit
überhaupt leute in diese unterscheidung
das ist doch mal den unterschied
zwischen dem konkreten menschen einen
anderen menschen und der menschheit
überhaupt ist der unterschied wieso kann
ich einem einzelnen menschen unter
umständen durch eine moralische pflicht
schaden hat dem entscheid überhaupt
schon würde es doch ihr anders aussehen
würde sagen wenn ich jetzt lüge schade
ich diesen konkreten menschen aber die
menschheit als solche die menschheit
gefasst als zu mehr anderen menschen
dies davon unbetroffen es würden doch
die meisten sicherlich sagen oder je
nachdem wie man menschen verstehen die
menschheit 2 steht der menschheit in
china oder indien und andere kontinent
der schade ich doch nicht dadurch dass
ich sie jetzt hier belügen zb etwas
falsches über immanuel kant erzählen
würden auch die meisten zahlen dann
schadet dort ich den menschen und was
sonst oder selbst in hamburg in armen
menschen hamburg schaltet oder wie sehen
sie es
die tour publikum darf gerne mitmachen
ja ich würde es machen jahren recht was
man dem entscheid ist angesagt
nicht schaden wenn man die menschheit
als etwas körperliches bekanntes jahres
eine abstrakte masse
sie schade allen dadurch sichern dass
gesellschaft und das ist gut
[Musik]
das ist allgemein können
ja genau
[Musik]
richtig also sie haben beide recht
menschheit meinte nicht die summe aller
menschen die entscheidende szene
abstrakter begriff entscheidend ist sie
eigentlich ein begriff
das verneinte vernünftigen koexistenz
von freien und bildung und ihre ihre
geregelte koexistenz wie ich schon sagt
durch rechte durch monate hindurch
verbinden und diese vernünftige form der
koexistenz die kath menschlichkeit die
würde der bewältigung unterminiert egal
wer einmal lügt dem glaubt man nicht
dass man wurde das sabotieren kommt das
ist für keine ganz richtigen
beschreibung als der mensch den
konkreten tierische mensch und die
menschheit abstrakte größe nicht nur so
mehr aller menschen die jetzt zu diesem
zeitpunkt auf der wendung lebens zum
angeblichen diese gutmütige lüge kann
aber auch durch einen zufall strafbar
werden nach möglichen gesetz das ratlos
und dem zufall der straffälligkeit
entgeht kann auch noch größeren gesetzen
als von rechten abgeurteilt werden
hast du nämlich ein leben jetzt mit
morgenpost umgehenden durch eine lüge an
der tat verhindert so bist du für alle
mieter aus dem springen möchten auf
rechtliche art verantworten bist du eure
strenge bei der wahrheit geblieben so
kann dir die öffentliche gerechtigkeit
nichts anderes
die unvorhergesehene folgen mag sein
welche simon es ist doch möglich dass
nachdem du den mörder auf die frage ob
der von ihnen angefeindet der zu hause
sein
ehrlicherweise sage antwortet hast diese
dort unbemerkt ausgegangen ist hin zu
den mördern nicht um den wurf gekommen
die tat also nicht geschafft wäre hast
du auch gelungen gesagt es sei nicht zu
hause und ist auch wirklich top zwar die
unbewusst ausgegangen wo denn der würde
geben
im weggehen begegnet in seine tat anrufe
nimmt so kannst du mit recht als urheber
des todes des selbst angeklagt werden
dann hättest du die wahrheit zu gucken
sie wusste es gesagt zu werden
vielleicht erhält dann über demnach
suchen seines weines im hause von herr
beil gelaufen nach begriffen verhinderte
worte
das scheint er zuerst mal ein bisschen
abstrus zu sein
diese findet ihr jetzt hier konstruiert
aber was ist jetzt ein hintergedanke
ja
[Musik]
ja es geht glaubt die richtige mischung
scheint als er das ist dass dieser
grundsatz war die programme zu leihen
[Musik]
des einen jahres
letztere garten
was worden waren ist ein hätte in davos
dass man ja aus diesen verträgen oder
menschheit also mit gesellschaft
aktionär
ja ich denke auch dass es in diese
richtung geht die ich glaube dass sie
kennt ihre folgen möchte also es geht
doch letztendlich darum dass kanzler
wir müssen unterscheiden von sowas immer
leitungen unter einstellungen oder
erinnerung handelt als die jetzt wenn
sich unser verhältnis zum sittengesetz
betreffen also es geht um das verhältnis
von unsere maxime zusammen
unsere einstellungen und auf der anderen
seite der konkreten handlungen in der
welt die davon irgendwie unabhängig ist
also wir beurteilen erkannt nicht
konkrete handlung eigentlich nehme meine
lücke davon aus die logik ist eigentlich
schon der handlung auch ein bisschen
glück ist nicht mit typische handlung
dass wir etwas mit der hand zu tun
während ein mord dies natürlich ein
typischer und kannten wir damit sagen
wir müssen auf der ebene der maximen
bleibt also unsere zu kriegen
handelsplätze und nur die betrachter und
konkrete taten und konkrete handlungen
von denen ihr spricht also das jetzt er
im dorf hier ist teilweise über tat
genug
normal haben und die konkreten
handlungen die dahinter im endeffekt
haus und springen und zwar durch zufall
die haben wir nicht gehabt auf die
sollte es uns nicht anderen das kann
sogar eher für uns problematisch werden
es soll nur wenn es um die frage etwas
getrübt die frage berücksichtigen
wie wir mit uns mit subjektiven
handlungs und setzten als unser
verhältnis zu bieten gesetzt wie wir
damit umgehen
alles an dritte konkreten handlungen
sind erstmal relevant weil sie zufällig
sind bringt es auch in seinem beispiel
der grundlegung zur metaphysik der
sitten
das erkannt gut oder böse ist allein ein
guter oder böser wille und sind es gut
nur ein unter bildung ein guter wille
sein wird während dem sie die handlungen
die aus einem guten willen und aus einem
wilden falls sich das konsequenz iannis
tische parat und des und die
touristische das klingt nicht ganz in
meiner das ganze zu verlassen
das heißt wenn wir wirklich handlungen
bewerben sondern müssten sich immer nach
den motiven schauen nach unserem
verhältnis zum sind besetzt wir können
eigentlich nie in der handlung bewährten
moralisch weil die handlung nicht mehr
ganz nur von uns abhängt sobald wir
ihnen die außen willen treten sobald
befindet aktiv werden kommen faktoren
mit hinzu die möbel einen unmittelbaren
hand und nicht so gravierend sein
aber wenn wir die handlungen mal weiter
ein bisschen zeit und raum verstreichen
lassen kommen dann notwendigerweise zu
fälle hinzu die die handlung begünstigen
oder erschweren können und das kann es
dann nicht mehr ganz zu gewesen
das ist so ein bisschen runterkommen
also und lüge scheint für ihn eigentlich
keine richtige handlung zu sein im sinne
der post berufen
sondern lüge ist eher sowas wie die
innere haltung es geht halt einfach um
daran dass er unser verhältnis ist jetzt
auch an der wand weise bestimmen
ja das würde uns eben wieder zu der
frage form eines unmoralischen müssen
die notwendige handlungen sein nein
müssen sie nicht typischen sinne das
nicht agieren als an eine handbewegung
bin ich lüge gewählte nicht die hand ich
sah mir sie kennen aber auf der anderen
seite diese
vor auszählung diesen ganzen sprach
pragmatiker diese sagt diese these dass
braut durch wörter dinge tun kann
ich kann natürlich auch etwas tun indem
wir das sagen aber es ist doch eine
andere form von handlung als wenn ich
jemanden töten das sind zwei
verschiedene ebenen im iran und kante
legt den fokus allein auf solche dinge
auch wenn die lüge sind außen
kommuniziert letztendlich müssen stimmen
und das führt mich wieder zu aristoteles
dessen unterscheidung von handlungen und
von effekten wenn ich vollständig zu
sein scheinen weil man so was wie eine
lüge das schwer mittel einbringen gut
lücke wäre natürlich ihre behandlung
aber mir scheint es wieder wärmer ist
eine einstellung des ja die neigung oder
haben kann würde sagen dann habe ich es
ja keine handlung und sie glaube wir
müssen wir noch einen weiteren bereich
berücksicht und die ganzen toten
die betreten eigentlich diesen inneren
bereich leiter habe so das motiv
die motive sind keine handlungen würde
ich sagen es im motiv ist im gründe für
die grundlage
was auch immer sie sind in handlung
vorgang also glück zum unschuldig er
dabei auch gesinnt sein mag
gutmütig ist jetzt nicht mit gut
vielleicht sitzen muss die folgen davon
selbst vor dem bürgerlichen gerichtshof
verantworten und dafür müssen zu uns
vorgesehen her gesehen sie auch über
seine wahrhaftigkeit politik ist jetzt
die basis aller auf ertrag zu gründenden
pflichten angesehen werden muss deren
gesetz will auch nur die geringste
anpassen an ein brett schranken und uns
gemacht wird 1 kittel wieder jetzt eine
basis die grundlage des vertraglich
verpflichtet vertraglich geregelten
gesetzlich geben zusammen was eben
natürlich unmöglich gemacht wird wenn
wir nicht mehr war ich kein zur maxime
namen das heißt sie würden eine maximal
zu fiktiven anti oscars werden in
bestimmten situationen bedürfe
und da fängt es schon an
woher wissen zudem dann genau anzugeben
dürfen oder nicht
sie müssen natürlich auch ganz sicher
sein dass es hierbei um einen
ungerechten mörder sich handelt der
jetzt ein ungerechtes opfer folgt ein
anderes unrecht erfolgt das opfer von
verfolgung so ein fall der das training
ganz klar auf der hand musste die immer
unsicherheiten geben könnte man jetzt
für canto argumentieren sind dass wir
den zwei eben immer die wahrheit zu
wie sehen sie es ja
es ist hier die meisten
wahrheit sagt
der ist
du bist
nach der pubertät
gute frage ja wie das heute juristisch
gesehen würden ich denke juristische 30
glaube ich für den staat aber müssen
mich auch immer schlimmer das sind die
fälle sachen so klar läge das dann
derjenige der lügt wegen beihilfe
angeklagt werden oder biomasse oder bei
[Musik]
schluss
und ich denke das ist es den reichen
lassen zwischen endlich gut und er
[Musik]
gut guter punkt dass man sagt ja aber es
gibt ja noch andere glichen denen die
pflicht zur wahrhaftigkeit wobei
natürlich ganz sagen wenn die pflicht
zur wahrhaftigkeit es die höchste
pflicht sich hat es gedauert
direkte in der regel pflicht also kann
unterscheidet man verschiedene pflichten
und die höchste pflicht ist auf jeden
fall von kann die der wahrhaftigkeit
erzähltes kategorischen imperativs sein
das könnte man aber sagen ich denke dass
es dann so eine form von ska touristik
wäre dann müsste man wirklich in dem
konkreten fall geht bis zu sagen was
konnte dem das so viel wissen und hatte
das dann müsste man also die
umständliche vermitteln müsse sagen
konnte derjenige der jetzt die den
mörder
da wahrhaftig das sagte wasser konnte er
wirklich wissen dass dadurch das opfer
getötet werden würde wenn es zum
beispiel sich jetzt nicht nur verstecken
würde zu einem bild sieht es opfer
direkt neben einem stände und sich
verkleidet hätte ja ja die perücke oder
überhaupt ist
und dann fragt neben der mörder ist es
jetzt der und zugang und müsst ihr
wirklich dem den fall wirklich und
abwägen müsste dann so eine
rechtfertigung argumentation entwickeln
aber man hätte probleme wie mir scheint
wegen beihilfe zum mord müssen sonst
vielleicht auch fahrlässigkeit
dabei sind aber da gebe es bestimmte
fälle unternehmer dann fallen würde
als niemand die wahrheit sagen würde
würde ist dann eben nicht mehr als
wahrhaftigkeit zu gericht interpretieren
sondern wahrscheinlich geben als
unterlassene hilfe darstellen oder hilfe
leistung also was mir standen aber ich
halte dieses beispiel für sehr
konstruiert muss ich sagen ich finde es
kann bringt es auf die spitze
ich finde das so dass solche fälle
eigentlich gesehen gibt es gibt
natürlich fälle wo eben in bestimmten
zeiten leute verfolgt werden kann man
sich gut vorstellen
da wird es dann wieder sehr konkret aber
im alltag glaube ich dass es kein gutes
beispiel ist mir nicht für solche
alternativen gestellt werden im alltag
haben wir hier das problem das wir lügen
wie wir mit mir scheint einfach um das
zusammenleben angenehmer zu machen also
dass man um es mal anders zu können
formulieren dass man sogar auf grund der
menschheit wie kann sie jetzt stehen
eben gerade lügen muss um dieses stabile
die stabile koexistenz überhaupt auf
rechts also dass man eben indem man wenn
man nur die wahrheit zahlen würde dass
man dann die menschheit als solche
zerstören würde nämlich die basis aller
verträge aufheben würde das jetzt nicht
gerne genau entgegengesetzt aktiv warum
weil wir die menschen geben und wie sehr
kranken würden weil mit der menschen
orientieren würden weil eben es zu viele
reibungen unserem alltäglichen ablauf
gibt natürlich muss man damit eher sagen
die aber wo macht man jetzt die grenzen
zu kleineren alltags lügen sind okay ich
würde auch sofort gehen kann
argumentieren lüge ist nicht sein und
wir können darüber diskutieren also mir
scheint es schon verschiedene vorhaben
zu geben zb zum schwachen leben die hier
annehmlichkeiten zu drücken dass wir
jemanden
die harte wahrheit erst sparen und dann
aber wege finden nehme es ihr angemessen
oder menschlicher mehr produkte
dass man also ich glaube schon dass man
dafür argumentieren kann
wie sehen sie es absolutes flugverbot
oder unterscheidung zwischen lieben
würde sagen wenn wir zu einem import
ausgehen dann hat absolut okay weil
ansonsten in den bereichen dass wir
diese arbeit ja das ist eine kleinigkeit
und selbst dann als salat sein und
bescheinigt hätten deswegen ihre bern
kennen also was ist gutes argument sind
sagt einem wo immer aufgefangen woran
wir noch einmal einmal der damm
gebrochen ist dann kann man immer wieder
gründe anführen bis zum mond fliegen
ihr habt gut
wer sagt die wahrheit
das ist die höchste maschine sind gar
nicht erkennt sogar um die angeblich
selber
mir bleibt entscheidend ist für mich
nutzen kinder stellung einen irgendwie
möglich ist das ist wahnsinn
hier war das abzweigen
man muss man müsste man geben diese
pflicht die sie jetzt als hilfe stift
müsste man eben genau eben noch die
grünen oder diskutieren zb nächstenliebe
oder sofas oder hilfsbereitschaft und
dann eben dieser einzelne ausnahmen
pflicht dass an dem ausnahme von der
pflicht
neben der pflicht der haft ich kite
gegenüberstanden
so müssten
bereits aufgetreten
funktionieren
die verantwortlichkeit behörde gesetzen
der pflicht
er setzt das schon verwirrt würde das
setzt voraus dass der däne fragt die
differenzen waren wir an
[Musik]
dann würde ein
das war okay die aktion bisher am
vormittag für den weg gewiesen dass er
es fragen also
[Musik]
ja man könnte auch sagen ich durfte
eigentlich den würde dann üben und zwar
deswegen weil wir mit seinem mit seiner
absicht bereits die menschheit als
solche bedrohung also eher gefährdet die
einheit dem entscheid die diesen
zusammenhalt durch seine absichten und
ich kann jetzt durch meine möge in dem
ich eben durch meine lüge seine welt
seine falsche wieder kommentieren
aber eben nicht die ganze menschheit
also könnte man versteht es argument
also dass er sagt der mörder mit gehe
davon aus der mörder hat bereits die
ordnung der zusammen den die menschheit
grundsätzlich gestört und ich muss jetzt
sozusagen seine welt nochmal störte den
frieden die lüge diesem fall annehmen
situation ausarbeitung des vertrags
gegeben so zu seinen hochzeiten ebenen
wir begeben uns auf seide und wir haben
den sei mittel von menschheit und ich
werde eine gemeinde von menschen
aber da wird es natürlich wieder spielt
und sich erlauben ihre ausnahmen und so
weiter und so fort
wir liegen damit nur sagen ich lange
rede kurzer sinn diesen interessantes
hausarbeit szene kann man eine ganz
tolle sache zu beschreiben ist als ein
heiliges unbedingt gebietes durch keine
konsumenten konventionen einzuschränken
dass fünf gebote in allen erklärungen
war das wohl denken und zugleich wichtig
ist hierbei er angst als anmerkung über
die verschreibung solcher strenger und
sich vergeblich ihn nun auf ausführbare
ideen verliert hier mit aber
verwerfliche konzept jedes mal sagt er
solche transaktionen beim als war bei
diesen grundsatz unannehmbare schreibt
so kommt es daher dass wir den mittleren
grundsatz nicht kennen der das mittel
der anwendung internen er führt sein
wird ansonsten wären der gleichheit
allzu ersten gesellschaftliche kette
bilden den rahmen an dass nämlich keine
anders als durch zusätzliche setze
kunden werden kann zu deren bildung er
mit ball getrennt hat und eines teams
eng zusammengezogen gesellschaft kann
diese grundsätze auf unmittelbare weise
angewendet werden und bedarf an einem
gewöhnlichen zu werden keines mit kantor
und satzes
aber in einer sehr zahlreichen
gesellschaft muss man einen neuen
grundsatz zudem noch hinzufügen den wir
hier einführen
dieser mittlerweile grundsatz ist dass
die einzelnen zur bildung der gesetze
wieder ereignen oder durch
stellvertreter beitrag
jetzt geht es um so konkrete fälle
das komme eigentlich bisschen springen
ich möchte ihnen jetzt mach hier was
zeigen nämlich zum schluss es gibt ein
promotion für das handbuch von
ausbildung bis zwang
und da gibt es auch eine anfrage über
den lügen und das möchte ich noch mal
kurz anschließend vorliegt selbstredend
sind die konsequenzen der lügen nicht
immer thematisch überdies auf will
politisch folge den ob direkt fast jede
lüge eine seltsame freiheitsberaubung
ich bin lieber falschinformation enthält
erhält wird sich fortan nicht länger so
verhalten wie er sich verhalten würde
wenn er die richtige information hätte
zu der höhe kommt es folglich dann mit
tatsachen die zur aufdeckung eines für
die lueg unangenehmen sachverhalts
führen kann
ausdrücklich verneint wenn gezielte
gegenteilige sachverhalte behauptet
werden das muss nicht immer nur durch
worte geschehen zum beispiel kann man
auch mit einem kopfnicken
moss oder auch zeitgenossen
kommunikative aktion die empfänger
falschen informationen zu spielen oder
ihn gezielt in die irre führen damit der
verbrauch lässt was der egoistischen
absicht des bundes liegt
wer lügt wenn als ein seinem gegenüber
eine situative störung adäquate war
wirklichkeit anpassung der für die
gelockerte person mit ihrem wahrnehmungs
velten handlungs spektrum eingeschränkt
und manipuliert damit es zu einer
situations deutschen und entscheidungen
sind des erfinders kommt und das ist
freiheitsberaubung spiegelt einem
menschen eine falsche welt vor und
reduzieren dadurch seine freiheit im
vergleich zu den zustand die man wäre
mit der wahrheit
ich glaube als lassen wenn wir nicht nur
auf jetzt den schaden an kommt die
meldung anderen anrichten sind ich
glaube dass
und herrn elemente problematik hat und
das scheint mir jetzt hier noch gut
ausgedrückt als lügner maßnahmen sich
die kontrolle von smart an information
angeliefert das betreffende gegen
relevant sein kann damit impliziert
jeder lüge eine art von missbrauch
erlebt nach einem nutzt die belogen
inflations logistischen zwecken und
versagte damit in der ersten dekade ist
eine person die sich ihre zwecke selbst
setzen können dabei sind grün zunächst
von akten klose täuschen zu
unterscheiden und zwar dadurch dass
dabei ausdrücklich unterhalten
konstatiert werden während das google in
einer täuschung ausreicht was du dir
doch das was das anders ist ganz einfach
zurück hängt man da war ich dies zum
beispiel durchaus möchte der blendung
durch mimisch gestisch abwehr von oder
schlicht durch schreiben
ein mensch kann also täuschen ohne
bereits zu lügen
und jetzt kommt hier das scheint mir
ganz interessant ist ein fluss eine
dimension der möge die vielleicht auch
für mangel kann es zu sprechen will dass
man gar nicht leben sollte derzeit die
lüge ist eine uhr start die sich
wiederholen und reproduzieren muss und
wirksam zu sagte bleiben oder anders
eine lüge zieht die nächste nach sich
denn wer in einer wichtigen
angelegenheit löw wird sich fortan dazu
genötigt sehen an der möge festzuhalten
um diese nur möglich durch weitere bögen
zu stützen
droht eine billige aufzufliegen kann es
mir durch weitere lügen
da mag es mit der zeit errichtung eines
vermeintlich immer perfekter belügen
gebäudes kommen ist allerdings rasch wie
ein kartenhaus einzustürzen droht sobald
nur eine der vielen löcher aus denen es
zusammengebaut ist aufgedeckt wird hier
geht einmal löwe immer nur dieses
geradezu zwanghafte der
produktionsmittel flügeln schlägt sich
auf althergebrachten reden 27
das schalten wir eine ganz wichtige
punkte seien möglich ist nicht nur
enttäuscht
einmalige ins antalya auf eine einzelne
situation bezogenen unmoralische form
sondern lüge hatte sich die tendenz
eines systems an eine verstrickung von
mym verbauen wo neben eine künstliche
welt aufrecht zu halten
und darin sehen sie das zur lüge sehr
viel intelligenz gehört uns ein
lügengebäude aufrecht zu halten immer
mit der ausflüchte zu finden um nicht
aufgedeckt zu werden
wer einmal
[Musik]
genau
und damit ist die weltordnung die
vernünftige wird ob die menschheit
gestört genommen genau das ist es und
ganz zum schluss ob das aber auch nur
der übergang zur nächsten sitzung
entscheiden wird hat ein buch
geschrieben in texas und david wird er
der these dass loewe gar nicht so
schlimm ist wie vor schritten
durchschritten ist folgendes als jemand
von ihnen dass es ist eine ode an
gittern ist jemand dem es total egal ist
das warten vor schluss als er sagt für
mich ist es nicht so schlimm ist weil
derjenige der lebt immer noch weiß dass
das was er tut falsches als er anerkennt
die wahrheit aber ein wunsch unter dem
ist die wahrheit zu kennen
deswegen gibt es noch vorne die
schlimmer sind als unternehmen und damit
wollen wir uns im nächsten sitzung
befassen
schauen sie haben ein bisschen kann
mitgehen darauf nahm den nächsten
sitzung ein und wenden es dann nur
ständig zu dann bis zum nächsten sitzen